[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
j'ai laissé partir mon avion et ça a été
une belle erreur une très belle erreur
puisque elle m'a permis de réaliser deux
de mes plus grands rêves traverser
l'amazonie et traverser l'atlantique
le 4 avril dernier j'étais à buenos
aires est en argentine et je devais
rentrer à paris pour trouver mon premier
emploi
le 4 avril dernier l'avion jj 2108 s'est
envolée sans moi je suis resté en
argentine à 11000 km de chez moi sans
aucun moyen de rentrer propulsé hors de
ma zone de confort cet après midi là
j'ai ouvert une grande carte du monde et
j'ai regardé un peu où j'étais bon bout
nos crs paris 11 mai de kilomètres on va
tracer deux traits ça doit pas être bien
compliqué le premier qui traverse toute
l'amérique latine et le second qui
traverse l'atlantique
j'ai tracé ces deux traits je n'avais
pas prévu grand chose le lendemain matin
j'ai mis mon sac sur le dos et je suis
parti duranleau premiers mois j'étais en
mouvement quasi permanent sur des
voitures dans des camions sur des
bateaux dans des pirogues parfois à pied
je n'ai pas arrêté d'avancer j'avais un
objectif simple et très clair
arrivé dans les caraïbes avant le 31 mai
d'où partent les derniers bateaux pour
l'europe
je me suis rapidement retrouvé à
l'entrée de l'amazonie je n'avais pas
bien réaliser que l'amazonie en cette
saison c'est la saison des pluies c'est
sain pour sa timidité c'est 35 degrés je
me suis mal je buvais jusqu'à 8 litres
d'eau par jour tellement je transpirais
en amazonie j'ai vécu des moments
fabuleux je me suis retrouvé à pêcher le
piranha a chassé le singe le crocodile
j'ai vu la nature comme je ne l'avais
jamais vu je peux vous dire que j'étais
pleinement heureux petit à petit je suis
arrivé au nord et je me suis retrouvé
dans les caraïbes
là le plan était tout nouveau durant
trois semaines
j'ai raconté à qui voulait bien
l'entendre mon projet voilà ce que je
viens de faire je viens de traverser
l'amazonie
et maintenant j'ai envie de prouver en
bateau qui me ramènerait en europe un
bon joueur et un capitaine qui m'a dit
écoute moi je te fais confiance je
t'emmène je monte sur le bateau on était
trois sur un voilier de 13 m ça fait
neuf mètres carrés habitables
je vous laisse imaginer la première
cuite et mes missions elle était simple
c'était faire d'eux car le premier de
12h à 16h et le deuxième vous vous en
doutez de minuit à 4 heures du matin
l'objectif c'était de régler un peu les
voiles et puis surtout de veiller les
cargos pour éviter de s'en prendre à en
pleine nuit et de couler lorsque nous
sommes partis
j'étais extrêmement excité durant les
trois premiers jours j'avais
l'impression d'être le héros d'un
serment d' aventure que je lisais plus
jeune je me voyais à la barre-de-monts
voilier traversant l'atlantique c'était
fabuleux
et puis au bout de trois jours j'ai
regardé derrière moi et la terre
commençait à disparaître
et puis un jour elle a complètement
disparu et là j'ai senti monter en moins
une vraie angoisse
je me suis dit ok là c'est parti c'est
dans le grand bain si jamais tu coules
battus peut pas rentrer la nage la
panique l'angoissent du radeau semaine
toutes les nuits je me réveillais
punique et des sueurs froides persuadé
que nous coulions et puis au bout de
deux semaines bon j'ai fait un petit
constat je me suis dit ok si tu dois
mourir autant de faire de manière
heureuse là j'ai commencé à me relâcher
et à profiter
j'ai mis un petit amas qu'à l'arrière du
bateau et puis je pêchais toute la
journée le soir je regardais un coucher
de soleil fabuleux à 360 degrés autour
de moi le matin j'allais jouer avec les
dauphins à l'avant du bateau
j'ai vraiment profité ça a été
incroyable et un beau jouet la tempête
s'est levée il en fallait bien une
cette tempête est la durée soixante
douze heures durant les premières heures
on avait déjà déchiré notre grand voile
c'est pas bon parce que la grand voile
c'est ton seul moteur quand tu es en
bateau on a fui cette tempête on devait
aller à l'est on est parti complètement
à l'ouest pour l'éviter durant ces 72
heures j'avais du mal à dormir et je ne
me nourrissait presque plus j'avais la
boule au ventre j'étais paniquée celle
angoisse c'est quelque chose que moi je
ne connaisse
pas du tout et d'un coup comme elle est
venue la tempête s'est calmée
le calme est revenu sur la mer et on a
entrepris de recoudre la grand voile
c'était notre seul moteur durant
quelques jours nous avons recousu la
grand voile
la traversée qui devait durer cinq
semaines on a duré 8
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en france
nous n'avions quasiment plus de vivre
plus d'eau est quasiment plus de
nourriture
on est arrivés par bus brûlés par le
soleil extrêmement fatigué mais
tellement heureux de ce qu'on venait de
réaliser
c'était magnifique moi je suis pas venu
ici pour vous raconter mon voyage non
sur le bateau j'ai eu beaucoup de temps
pour réfléchir et mon principal sujet de
réflexion c'était celui-là c'était de me
dire tu as tu viens de traverser
l'amazonie était sur le point de
traverser l'atlantique
mais t'as rien d'exceptionnel ton
expérience de la forêt résume à un camp
scout et ton expérience de la voilà un
stage de catamaran
comment ça se fait que toi tu lis arrive
alors j'ai vraiment réfléchi cogiter ça
m'a pris du temps mais j'en avais du
temps pas de soucis 50 dos en mer c'est
autant de faire 24 heures à regarder
l'océan et à se poser mille questions et
j'ai trouvé 5.5 clé que je vais vous
livrer ce soir vous en ferez est ce que
vous voudrez mais moi c'est des clés que
je vais m'efforcer de suivre tout au
long de ma vie
la première c'est d'être inconscient au
moment où je laisse partir mon avion je
suis complètement inconscient je suis
revenu à cette date d'enfants vous savez
on parle de rêve d'enfant quand on se
dit tout est possible quand on est
enfant on se dit tiens j'ai envie d'être
cosmonaute on n'imagine pas toutes les
barrières qui peuvent se mettre sur
votre route avant d'être cosmonautes
bien moi c'était pareil je l'avais pas
du tout conscience des barrières je
savais qu'il y en aurait bien sûr mais
j'en ai fait complètement abstraction
vous vous souvenez j'ai mis mon sac sur
le dos et je suis parti je me suis fait
confiance finalement et ça c'est la
deuxième clé c'est de se faire confiance
parce que quand je me fais confiance bon
je crois en mon projet et quand je crois
mon projet il ya une positivité qui
émane de moi j'arrive à persuader les
autres à les convaincre
ça je m'en suis rendu compte j'ai réussi
à embarquer tout un nombre de personnes
avec moi qui a adhéré à mon projet au
moins qu'il écoutait et c'est ce qui m'a
permis de
réaliser la troisième clé c'est
évidemment de faire confiance en les
autres parce que on ne peut pas réaliser
des projets impossibles comme celui ci
sans se faire aider par les autres et
moi j'ai été extrêmement aidé par tout
un nombre de personnes alors bien sûr
faire confiance en chaque personne que
je rencontrais ça m'a joué des tours
vous vous en doutez et pourtant ça a été
la source des plus belles rencontres de
ma vie la quatrième clé c'est d'avoir un
objectif le mien était très simple aller
au nord puis trouver un bateau cet
objectif clair il me permet de
visualiser mon rêve je vois ce que je
veux aller et le permet de le montrer
aux autres je me souviens qu'un
camionneur argentin m'a emmené sur 1500
km dans son camion on a pris 17 heures
pour faire le trajet à la fin j'étais un
petit peu camionneurs moi même et
pourquoi est ce qui m'a emmené parce que
moi je lui racontais mon projet j'ai
onze mille kilomètres à faire voilà ce
que je veux faire voilà où est ce que je
voudrais aller est ce que tu peux pas
m'emmener à la ville suivante il s'est
dit pas oui tout à fait et lui il s'est
vu contribuer à mon rêve
ayez un objectif clair et exprimer le et
la dernière clé c'est de faire confiance
en leurs prévu
l'imprévu c'est la source de tous les
bonheurs et de toutes les difficultés
il y avait pour moi mille route pour
traverser l'amérique latine
pourtant je n'en ai pris qu'une seule
celle que l'imprévu a décidé pour moi un
coup la route était bloquée un coup là
le bus ne partait pas un coup le bateau
prenait 15 jours à faire la traversée
qui était prévue pour trois et ses
imprévus ils ont été des sources de
moments extrêmement pénible je voulais
dire et de moments incroyables
c'est toute cette traversée qui moi m'a
rempli de bonheur finalement arrivé à
traverser ni traverser l'atlantique
c'est pas ça qui m'a vraiment rendu
heureux c'est vraiment tout le trajet
toutes ces difficultés qui vont
construite et qui m'ont évidemment fait
grandir martin luther king disait vives
et les rêves que la vie vous défie de
rêver et moi je pense comme lui que nos
aspirations les plus profondes sont de
réaliser ses rêves que nous avons depuis
tout petit c'est ça qui nous rend
vraiment heureux et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire
voilà j'espère que tous ces conseils ne
vous ont pas semblé trop bateau et
pourtant si c'est le cas souvenez vous
qu'il ya un océan entre vous et vos
rêves et que vous ne traverserait pas à
pied merci
[Applaudissements]